Meter hohe Flammen und Rauch über den
Brocken das sind Bilder hier aus
Deutschland lichterloh brennt der Wald
in einem gesperrten Teil über dem
Nationalpark im Harz rund 150 Hektar
stehen in Flammen das Feuer war am
Samstag in der Nähe des Aussichtspunktes
Goethe Bahnhof entdeckt worden die
Brandursache ist noch unklar also schon
wieder Feuer in unseren deutschen
Wäldern schon wieder brennt der
Nationalpark Harz Katastrophenfall die
Feuerwehr ist mit löschhubschraubern um
mehreren Einsatzfahrzeugen im Einsatz
die Waldbrandgefahr im Harz ist
inzwischen auf Stufe 3 verschärft worden
und heute soll das Feuer dann mit
verstärkten Kräften aus der Luft
bekämpft werden mit Tagesanbruch sollen
dann mehr Hubschrauber und auch zwei
Löschflugzeuge aus Italien Wasser auf
die Brandherde abwerfen vor Ort ist
unser Kollege Benny Müller der
Nationalpark Harz schwer zugängliches
Gelände viele abgestorbene Fichten das
Feuer wütet bereits seit mehreren
Stunden wie ist die Lage aktuell bei dir
ja wie man sehen kann hinter mir
befindet sich der Brocken die betroffene
Anlage man sieht Rauchschwaden an der
Handlage es brennt immer noch auf großer
Fläche immer wieder kommen hier
Hubschrauber an und werfen Wasser ab das
sind Hubschrauber der Bundespolizei ein
Hubschrauber der Bundeswehr aber auch
zwei Hubschrauber eines privaten
Unternehmens aus der Schweiz und
Österreich sind hier unterwegs
nichtsdestotrotz die Wassermenge reicht
nicht deswegen hat man hier auf
internationaler Ebene Hilfe ersuchen
gestartet und hier auch eine Antwort aus
Italien bekommt um 9 Uhr sollen hier
zwei Luft
zwei Löschflugzeuge tschuldigung zwei
Löschflugzeuge Wasser herbringen da
diese viel größere Wassermassen bringen
können als es die Hubschrauber bereits
tun
ausgebrochen ist das Feuer an einem der
meistgenutzten Wanderwege im Harz auch
ein Moor soll jetzt betroffen sein das
ist der Albtraum für die Feuerwehr denn
moorbrände sind extrem schwer unter
Kontrolle zu bekommen warum
das Feuer bei moorbränden das ludert
natürlich in der Erde das die der Boden
ist sehr tief das Feuer sitzt sehr tief
es ist nicht wirklich auszumachen wo ist
denn noch brennt und selbst wenn es den
Anschein macht das gefeuer gelöscht zu
haben
lodert das Feuer weiter das heißt man
muss hier viel Wasser rauf bringen und
das ist in diesem schwierigen Gebiet mit
vielen Stangen Steilhang lagen wie die
Feuerwehr sagt sehr gefährlich und zudem
kommt es natürlich auch noch dazu dass
die Baumkronen also die Wipfel von den
Bäumen von den abgestorbenen Bäumen hier
immer wieder herabstürzen und dann eben
dafür sorgen oder beziehungsweise die
Gefahr groß ist dass hier Einsatz
Greifkräfte schwer verletzt werden wie
geht es denn jetzt weiter wann könnte
dieser Großbrand denn gelöscht werden
zu Prognosen will sich die Feuerwehr
hier noch nicht hinreißen lassen wir
haben hier noch eine Situation die nicht
unter Kontrolle ist wie ist die
Feuerwehr sagt man wartet hier
händeringend eben auf diese Flugzeuge
man hat hier heute morgen eine
Videokonferenz mit den Piloten um 7:30
Uhr mit den Piloten gehalten jetzt
wartet man eigentlich sekündlich darauf
dass die Flugzeuge am Concordia See im
Harz beladen und dann hier die ersten
Wassermassen runterwerfen wie lange das
dauern wird und bis wann das Feuer dann
tatsächlich unter Kontrolle ist dazu
will hier niemand was sagen
verfolgst das für uns vor Ort weiterhin
vielen Dank für den Moment Benny Müller
[Musik]